hey Lauren let's go I thought we were
going to vote for ice cream sorry I'm
trying to cleanse my data and it's
taking so much longer than I thought and
I'm trying to learn Python and it's just
not going well what why Google has a
managed service for this called ADA prep
let me show you
you
let's get right into the data prep tool
if you're using the data prep for the
first time accept the approvals and give
it a couple of seconds to load we can
start by creating a flow give it a name
and description and click create you
have the option of importing data either
from your local machine Google cloud
storage or bigquery for this demo we are
going to use cloud storage bucket
I have pre-loaded a few ice cream sales
datasets into cloud storage this is the
data set I will use for the data prep
flow click on the data set you want to
begin the transformation width and click
on edit recipe a recipe contains a
sequence of steps that transforms the
selected data set into a new data set
the Wrangell language is used to create
recipes Oh rango language if I still can
I have to learn another programming
language actually no brand new language
is large rate formulas you see in Google
sheets and you don't have to write it on
your own a lot of it is auto-generated
for you ok good let's keep going for
this demo we will build tasks performed
by data analyst regularly like cleansing
structuring and enriching as you can see
this is the basic view of how data looks
across different columns and rows after
looking at data you might see some
mismatched values and read for one of
the columns upon clicking it you might
realize that something was wrong with
the data in this case the add symbol in
the number field the tool also gives you
some auto suggestions for this column to
choose from I'm going to fix this column
by using a value given to me by the
business analyst for a typical serial
number split by delimiter allows you to
separate values in the same column by a
delimiter in this case the forward slash
I'm going to rename these columns now
for better understanding we can also
easily join multiple data sets in just
few clicks
let's join to Delta sets with one of the
existing data set that we have loaded in
the flow type ID is automatically
detected as the join key and you can
choose which column you want to display
for both the data sets post the joint
function to hide a column simply
right-click on the column and hide it
similarly I'm going to be joining one
more data set using flavor ID to further
enrich my data changing data types is
super simple as well let's remove the
percentage symbol from the profit margin
percentage column and convert it into
integer data type
lastly let's apply some custom logic to
create a new data column the case
function allows you to perform multiple
conditional tests on a set of
expressions with a statement you're I'm
going to define a range of profit
sentiments from low medium and high
based on the ranges of the value they
might fall in after these steps my
pipeline is now ready to run I'll select
a couple options for how I want my
results to be stored I can also choose
if I want the job to run manually or
scheduled and voila we can run the draw
wow this is really cool and easy once I
create the recipes I can run the jobs
anytime and I don't even need to learn
Python absolutely can we now eat our ice
creams don't forget to subscribe for
more great Google cloud platform content
thanks for watching